[Musique]
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa ce mois ci
c'est le mois du cinéma d'animation
comme tous les ans au mois d'octobre on
fait des focus sur le cinéma d'animation
et cette année on a décidé de faire un
focus sur le cinéma d'animation japonais
comme on le fait très souvent parce
qu'en plus il ya des films extrêmement
importants qui sont sortis les six
derniers mois et on n'avait pas eu
l'occasion de les passer donc vous allez
pouvoir éventuellement les revoir
éventuellement les rattraper on va vous
diffuser pendant une toute une partie du
mois d'octobre les films le mystère des
pingouins wonderland le royaume sans
pluie et les enfants de la mer avec en
particulier le samedi 19 octobre une
soirée après midi soirée animation
qui commence à 16 heures et qui finira à
23h avec les trois films que je viens de
citer
chaque film à 3,060 si on organise cette
soirée c'est aussi parce que sentir
comme l'année dernière organise un
concours de dessin manga et que le
samedi 19 octobre
on vous en dira plus dans la salle du
cinéma les yeux d'elsa
alors rendez vous nombreux pour
découvrir ces trois films l'un les deux
l'autre comme vous voulez en tout cas le
19 octobre vous pourrez découvrir ces
films qui ont qui ont été des très
grands succès et qui sont pour certains
issus de deux mangas extrêmement connue
à très bientôt au cinéma les idazza
[Musique]